sherlock holmes ardent défenseur des
notes de jazz à part pour celui que vous
venez de passer
sherlock noces
vous savez ce que font les nains de
jardin quand nous avons le dos tourné
la voie est libre vous pensez qu'ils
passent leur temps à s'amuser
nous avons toute la vie devant nous fini
tout le monde à sa place que tout va
bien dans le meilleur des mondes et non
quand lemon jardin disparaissent
juliette
ils ont tous disparu il n'y en a qu'un
qui peut mener l enquête
sherlock une hausse
fervent défenseur des nains de jardin
fervent défenseur
à part pour celui que vous venez de
casser car si le 11 avril
un terrible danger menacées nos jardins
par le réalisateur de kung fu panda
quitte à personne ils veulent nous
réduire en miettes tous avant demain
soir l'un d'eux trois parties nous
devons traverser le fleuve
il nous faut une bassine ou un bol on
n'a pas de bol sherlock pour une
incroyable aventure
le prochain avis se trouve dans le parc
d'idées nous suivait la ligne bleue
tracée au sol jusqu'à la punaise rouge
géante
attention une pique
nous devons être très discrets clancy de
pas en avant
stop j'ai dit stop je n'ai pas
l'habitude d'être le postérieur d'un
écureuil nous sommes repérés
sherlock qui n'ont aucun écureuils ne se
trémousse de la sorte banking fait plus
une démonstration au cinéma le 11 avril